hey Conan O'Brien here I am very excited
of course season 1 if Conan O'Brien
needs a friend big smash hit only
problem is none of them became my real
friends they're all show business
phonies don't return my calls
so we're starting season 2 my first
episode with David Letterman is dropping
right now we've got an amazing season
we've got David Letterman that we've got
Tina Fey John Oliver Malcolm Gladwell
Sarah Silverman the list goes on and on
and on that's just the tip of the
iceberg and joining me all along my true
compatriot and assistant Sona love ceci
and hey Sona hi no no that was that was
just a little off and thank you for
being my real friend thank you
well you pay me so I'm not a real friend
most real friends are paid that's not
true that's how I understand it
completely not my whole life my parents
paid younger children to be my friends
story yeah you're sad is my happy anyway
check out the new season it's everywhere
it's on Spotify you can get it on Apple
you can get it on stitcher
where else Google a podcast Google
podcast you can get it on mojo from a
shopper to do scripts clop top top you
can get it on what is it halfpipe is it
on half lion half pipe I don't know
check it out if you don't know what it
is what the kids are doing now season
two you got to check it out fantastic
right now me David Letterman we never
talked before until this moment this is
fantastic
we're in the woods where are we I have
no idea